hi guys welcome and today's topic is on
AWS auto scaling so this is uh kill I
would be taking up a tutorial on the
auto scaling but before that I would
request you guys to subscribe our
channel the link you can find below this
video at the right side let's begin with
our tutorial and let's look into what we
have in a today's session so I would be
covering up why we require a W sort of
scaling what is a double use auto
scaling what are the benefits of using
the scaling service how these auto
scaling works the different scaling
plans we have what is the difference
between the snapshot and the AMI
what is the load balancer and how many
types of load balancers we have and
along with that I would be covering up a
real-life demo on the ADA place let's
begin with why we require AWS auto
scaling now before AWS cloud scaling
there was question in the mind of
enterprises that they were spending a
lot of money on the purchase of the
infrastructure if they have to set up
some kind of the solution so they have
to purchase an infrastructure and
one-time cost was required so that was a
burden for them in terms of procuring a
server hardware software in and then
having a team of experts to manage all
those infrastructure so they used to
think that no longer they require these
resources if there was a cost-efficient
solution for their project that was the
project manager gives two things now
after the UW's clout scaling that was
introduced automatically the auto
scaling maintains the application
performance based on the user
requirements at the lowest possible
price so what does the auto scaling does
is that whenever there is a scalability
require it manages it automatically and
hence the cost optimization became
possible now what is aw sort of scaling
let's look into deep so AWS auto scaling
is a service that helps users to monitor
their applications and the servers
and automatically adjust the capacity of
the infrastructure to maintain the
steadiness so they can increase the
capacity they can even decrease the
capacity also for the cost optimization
and also predictable performance at the
lowest possible cost now what are the
benefits of auto scaling it gives the
better fault tolerance applications you
can get the server's created and you can
have a blown copy of the service so that
you don't have to deploy the
applications again and again better the
cost management because the scalability
is decided by the AWS automatically
based on some threshold parameters it
was a reliable service and whenever the
scaling is created or initiated you can
get the notifications onto your mail IDs
or to your cell phone's scalability as I
mentioned is always there in the auto
scaling it can scale up it can scale
down as well and it has the flexibility
the flexibility in terms of whenever you
want to schedule it if you want to stop
it if you want to keep the size of the
servers at a fixed number or you can
always make two changes on the fly and
the better availability now with the use
of the auto scaling we come around with
the terminology called snapshot and the
ami let's look into the difference
between the snapshots and the ami
snapshots versus a mine so in a company
there was one of the employee that was
facing an issue with launching the
virtual machines so he asked his
colleague a question is it possible to
launch multiple virtual machines with a
minimum amount of time because it takes
a lot of time in terms of creating the
virtual machines
the other colleagues said that yes it is
possible to launch multiple ec2 instance
and that can be done at a lesser time
and with the same configuration and this
can be done either you use a snapshot or
EMI on the AWS then the colleague said
that what are the differences between
the snapshot Nami let's look into the
difference now the snapshots basically
kind of a backup of a single EBS volume
which is just like a virtual hard drive
that is attached to the ec2 instance
whereas the AMI it is basically used as
a backup of an ec2 instance all the
snapshots ops for this when the instance
contain multiple static EBS swallow when
you are for the snapshot whenever the
instance contains multiple statics EBS
volumes EMI this is widely used to
replace the field or ec2 instance in the
snapshots here you pay only for the
storage of the modified data whereas
with a mine you pay only for the storage
that you use
the snapshots are non bootable images on
ABS volume whereas ami are beautiful
images on the ec2 instance how we're
creating an ami image will also create
the EVs snapshots now how does a w sort
of scaling work let's look into it so
for the AWS auto scaling to work you
have to configure single unified scaling
policy per application resource and this
scaling policy with that you can explore
the applications also and then select
the service you want to scale also for
the optimization select do you want to
optimize the cost or do you want to
optimize the performance and then keep
track of scaling by monitoring or
getting the notifications
now what are the different scaling plans
we have so in the auto scaling a scaling
plan basically helps a user to configure
a set of instructions for scaling based
on the particular software requirement
the scaling strategy basically guides
the service of AWS auto scaling on how
to optimize resources in a particular
application so it's basically kind of
the parameters that you set it up so
that how the resource optimization can
be achieved in the auto scaling with the
scaling strategies users can create
their own strategy based on their
requirements and thresholds and this can
be changed on the fly as well one of the
two types of scaling policies we have so
they are basically dynamic scaling and
the predictive scaling now what is
dynamic scaling it basically guides the
service of AWS auto scaling on how to
optimize the resources and it is helpful
in optimizing resources for availability
and particular price now with scaling
strategies users can create their plan
based on the requirements and thresholds
so it a metric can be like let's say a
network in network out or it can be a
CPU utilization memory utilization
likewise now in the predictive scaling
its objective is to predict future
workload based on daily and weekly
trends and regular forecasts future
network traffic so it is kind of a
forecast that happens based on the
previous past experiences it uses a
machine learning technique for analyzing
that network traffic and this scaling is
like how weather forecast works right it
provides schedule scaling actions to
ensure the resource capacity is
available for application requirement
now with the auto scaling you would need
the load balancers also because if there
are multiple instances that are created
then you would need a load balancer to
distribute the load to those instances
so let's understand what do we mean by a
load balancer a load balancer basically
acts as a reverse proxy and it is
responsible for distributing the network
or the application traffic across
multiple servers with the help of a load
balancer
you can achieve a reliability you can
achieve a fault tolerance an application
that is basically it increases the fault
tolerance and the reliability so for
example when there is a high network
traffic that is coming to your
application and if that much traffic
comes to your application to the
instances your instances may crash so
how you can avoid that situation so you
need to manage the network traffic that
is coming to your instances and that can
be done with the load balancer so thanks
to the AWS load balances which helps in
distributing network traffic across
back-end servers in a way that it
increases performance of an application
here in the image you can see the
traffic coming from a different
resources landing on to the ec2 instance
and the load balancer is actually
distributing that traffic to all the
three instances hence managing the
network traffic quite properly now what
are the types of load balancers we have
and there are three types of load
balancers on the AWS one is the classic
load balancer second is the application
load balancer and the third one is the
network load balancer let's look into
what we have in the classic load
balancer so the classic load balancer is
the most basic form of load balancing
and we call it as a primitive load
balancer also and it is widely used for
the ec2 instances it is based on the IP
address and the TCP port and it routes
network traffic between end users as
well as between the back-end servers and
it does not support whose based routing
and it results in low efficiency or
resources let's look into what we have
in the application load balancer this is
one of the advanced forms of load
balancing it performs the task on the
application level in the US I model it
is used when there are HTTP and HTTPS
traffic routing is required and also it
supports the host based and pathways
routing and performs well with the micro
services or the backend applications
the network load balancer performs the
task at layer four of the connection
level in the OSI model the prime role of
the network load balancer is to route
the TCP traffic and it can manage a
massive amount of traffic and is also
suitable to manage the low latency s
let's look into the demo and see how
practically we can create the order
scale hi guys let's look into the demo
for how we can create an order scaling
on the AWS console so right now I am
logged in to the AWS console and I am in
the Mumbai region what you need to do is
you have to go to the compute section
and under that click on the ec2 service
let's wait for the ec2 servers to come
you
now just scroll down and under the
load-balancing there is an option called
auto-scaling so there first you have to
create a launch configuration and then
after that you have to create the
auto-scaling verbs so click on launch
configuration and then you have to click
on create launch configurations
so click on create' launch configuration
now this launch configuration is
basically this set of parameters that
you define while launching an auto
scaling so that this uniformity is
maintained with all the instances so
that includes let's say if you select
the Windows OS or a Linux OS that
particular type of an operating system
will be implemented in all the instances
that will be part of an auto scaling so
there are certain set of parameters that
we have to specify during the launch
configuration so that we can have a
uniformity in terms of launching the
servers so here I would select an Amazon
Linux ami and then I would select the
type of server which will be T to dot
click on configure
details put the name to the launch
configuration let's say we put it as a
demo and the rest of the things will
keep it default click on add storage
since it's a linux ami we can move with
the 8 GB storage that should be fine
click on configure security group let's
create a new security group which has
the SSH port open and that is open for
any where which is basically a source
ipv4 and ipv6 ilex any IP will be able
to access that click on review just
review your launch configuration if you
want to make changes you can do that
otherwise click on create launch on the
ocean you would need the key pair and
this key pair will be a unique key pair
which will be used with all the
instances that are part of the auto
scaling group so we can select an
existing key pair if you have that
otherwise you can create a new key pair
so I have an existing keep here I will
go with that
acknowledge it and click on create
launch valuation
now we have successfully launched the
configuration of an auto scaling the
next thing is to create an auto scaling
group so click on create an auto scaling
group using this launch configuration
put a group name let's say we put
something like test and the group size
to start with it says one instance so
that means at least a single instance
will always be running and it will be
initiated and running 24/7 till the
auto-scaling is available you can
increase the size of the minimum base
instances also let's say you can change
it to two also so you would get at least
two servers running all the time so
we'll go with one instance the network
would be the BBC default and in the VP
Seaford particular region we can select
the availability zones so let's say if I
select availability zone one a and then
available is on one B so how the
instances will be launched so one
instance will be launched in money the
other one in B one B the third one in
the one a fourth one in the world
likewise it will be equally spread among
the availability zones
next part is to configure the scaling
policies so click on it if you want to
keep this group at its initial size
let's say if you want to go with only a
single instance or two instances and you
don't want the scaling to progress you
can put it keep this group at its
initial size so this is basically a way
to halt the scaling but we will use the
scaling policies to adjust the capacity
of this group so click on it and we
would scale between let's say minimum
one instance that we have and we scale
it between one to four instances and
what condition on what basis these
instances will be scaled up or scaled
down would be defined in the scale group
size so the scaling policies you can
implement based on a scale group size or
using the simple scaling policies using
the steps so in the scale group size you
have certain metrics you can use average
CPU utilization you can define a metric
related to average net worth in average
net work out or the load balancer
request counts per target and if you
create the simple scaling policies using
steps then you need to create the alarms
and there you can get some more metrics
that you can add up as a parameter for
the auto scaling
let's go with the scaling group size
let's go with the metric type as average
CPU planation and the target value here
you have to specify what would be the
threshold that when the instance CP
utilization is crossed then a new
instance should be initiated so you can
put a reasonable threshold for that
let's say we put something like 85% and
whenever the instance CPU utilization is
crossed 85% threshold or you will see
that there will be a new instance
created let's go to the next configure
notifications and here you can add
notifications so let's say if there is a
new instance that is initiated and you
want to basically be notified so you can
get notifications over your email ids or
you can get it on the cell phones so for
that for adding the notification you
would eat the SNS service that is called
as a simple notification service and you
have to create a topic there you have to
subscribe for the topic using your email
ID and then you should get the
notifications click on configure tags
the tags are not mandatory you can
basically put the tag let's say if you
want to identify the instance or purpose
it was created otherwise you can leave
it blank also click on review and review
your scaling policies notification tags
as well as the scaling group details
click on create auto scaling group and
here you go your scaling has been
launched click on close
and you should get at least a single
instance initiated automatically by the
water scaling
so let's read for the details to appear
so here you can see
on launch configuration name demo auto
scaling group name test minimum instance
we want one the maximum instances we
want four we have selected to
availability zones 80 south 180 South 1b
and the instance one has been initiated
and if you want to verify where exactly
this instance has been initiated just
click on the instances here and here you
will see that our single instance has
been initiated that is in service and
that has been initiated and Navy salt
rugby now once the threshold of this
instance crosses 85% that is what we
have defined in the scaling policies
then you should see that another
instance will be initiated so likewise
this is basically I have created steps
to initiate a scaling policy that means
to increase the number of servers
whenever the threshold crosses likewise
here itself you can add another policy
to scale it down the resources in case
if the CPU utilization goes to a normal
value fine guys that's it from us
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Turner DUP and get certified
click here